[Music]
when i wrote about jim dooley in
lisey's story i was thinking very much
of the man
who shot john lennon because this guy
was a fan
he was a huge fan of lennon's and before
shooting him to death he got lennon to
sign
an album and i thought to myself
yeah i can see that happening
dooley really looks at scott's novels as
like scripture you know he lives by them
he breathes them they're
everything to him
there was a lot of conversations between
pablo and steven
and ultimately myself about what to do
with this character and
adding scenes to make him something more
relatable and
more real daily is a very gifted actor
that can make a very simple sort of
regular scene into something very
complicated just by his presence
it's easy to play a stone rock billion
that is just a mean person
i think what dane did so beautiful is
that he was also
able to create a fragile man
in this context of the billion and that
fragility
makes him vulnerable and that
vulnerability it's fascinating because
it's hard
prof this is amazing and it's only the
tip of the iceberg there's plenty more
just waiting for us
what did you do look whatever it is i
need you to stop
listen listen listen there's a story in
here about a father and his two sons i'm
pretty sure it's the prequel to the
coaster's daughter he talked about one
time on npr
it's fantastic but when people read this
where did you get it she gave it to me
easy as pie told you i was good at
persuading people
you